It's well-known...
...that some gestures mean different things in different parts of the world.
In some places such as Britain, this means everything is okay,...
...while in Brazil and other places, it's considered obscene,...
...and in still other places such as Japan, it means money.
In Italy, they might make this sign to emphasize a point,...
...while in Jordan, it can mean wait a second.
Certain things often have gestures for them.
For instance, in most places where drinking alcohol is popular,...
...there's a sign for drinking or getting drunk.
In the U.S., it's this...
...while in France, they grab and twist their nose,...
...and in Russia, they flick their throat.
On the other hand, some places have more or less unique gestures.
In Russia, to say you're making things too complicated,...
...you scratch your ear by going around the back of your head.
Among the most common and probably oldest gestures...
...are nodding for yes and shaking the head for no.
But even this isn't universal.
Bulgarians are famous for shaking their head to mean yes...
...and nodding with a click of the tongue to mean no.
And in South Asia, they have a third option,...
...which involves tilting the head from side to side.
It's used to acknowledge the person speaking to you,...
...although in some contexts, it can also mean approval or even uncertainty.